many people are arriving in Cyprus
utterly traumatized and too upset to
talk about what they've been through to
get here
Dr abdraman his four sons and his wife
landed on this plane late in the
afternoon they had to leave her parents
behind everything is
like a lot of houses has been bombarded
we lost friends colleagues and his
streets were really unsafe scary so it
was surprising
what was it like it was like it was like
we it was kind of diary because we had
to go upstairs
because downstairs is more safer because
they normally hit upwards and it might
in my eyes yeah and you're glad to be
safe now yes
oh my God
this is what they've escaped from
the 72-hour ceasefire is barely holding
but it has given people a chance to get
out of hiding and stock up on food what
little there still is
very few hospitals are still running
those that are are chaos
if there is space the RAF flights are
bringing out other nationalities too
that'll tie up is Australian he came in
on a British flight looking to the road
and you see someone holding an AK
looking at you and you just walk right
back home so that's what you could do
you can't say nothing you can't do
anything stay home be sheltered so they
come knocking at your door
you know and that's what's going to
happen soon you know because um there's
a famine going on right now it's just
shortages of food Water
Supplies nothing's open nothing's
bringing supplies in people are running
out and sooner or later they're going to
start jumping over doors extorting
houses
within hours of arriving in Cyprus the
evacuees are put on charter flights back
to the UK at least two left today this
is the fourth British military flight to
arrived in Cyprus Downing Street say
that by the end of the day eight will
have come here they have a very small
window with a lull in the fighting in
which to try and get as many people out
as possible
that window is closing fast
UK troops are now taking a
responsibility of the Airfield north of
hatum from German forces the Aria
flights will continue for as long as
they are able to hundreds possibly
thousands are still trapped Alistair
bunker Sky News in Cyprus